اقبال متزايد على استخدام المحافظ الرقميه
في السعوديه مع التسهيلات التي قدمتها تلك
المحافظ في عمليات تحويل الاموال المحلي
والدولي ودفع رواتب العماله وشراء التذاكر
والسلع من المتاجر والمواقع الالكترونيه
بسيطه
يعني حل من الحلول يعني سريعه في المجال
الصراحه يعني فتره طويله جدا ما استخدمت
همم
الدفع النقدي
الكثير من الشباب في السعوديه يرون ان
المحافظ الرقميه اهتمت باضافه خدمات تلبي
احتياجاتهم مثل خدمه المحفظه المشتركه
التي تتيح للمج اضافه الاموال فيها دون
الحاجه لبيانات بنكيه وتسهل حساب القيمه
المطلوبه من كل فرد يعني بالنسبه لي انا
الاعتماد عليها اسهل عن طريق الجوال ممكن
اطلع الجوال احاسي فيها اي مكان اييه بعض
الاحيان احنا والشباب في الاستراحه قطاعه
شيء
صار شيء لا يعني محوله رضينا اكثر شيء
صراحه استخدمها اللي قطه الشباب يعني
بالاول خذ الايبان واكيد الرقم واخذ رقم
الحساب وصلنا وصل الحين خلاص ابحث اشوف
الاسم وعلى طول حول بعدين نحوي اربعه
اعوام من اطلاق محفظتي اس تي سي بي بلغت
عمليات التحميل لتطبيقها على الهواتف
الذكيه اكثر من 21 مليون عمليه تحميل
الامر الذي يشير الى التطورات المتتابعه
في اسلوب التعاملات الماليه في البلاد
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه